[Music]
thirty full seconds of this disney
castle magic bolt i swear every movie
stretches this another full second walt
disney rips off warner brothers harry
potter fogg because why the hell not
higher to the caribbean nine the Alice
Chronicles target to quote at full sail
will tip us over exactly how old do you
expect us to rescue Jack Sparrow
I mean reached the playing card base
Neverland she said port yet the ship was
tilting starboard which further proves
that no one on this ship knows what
they're doing
ships hitting the bottom like this do
not continue to gain speed this works
and everyone lives and no one has heard
and the ship's not damaged 60 seconds of
bullshit how work here is done freaking
those pirates to a watery grave that was
your work here oh good it's still in a
boat still might as well be a pirates
movie Amistad - or Cloud Atlas oh look a
Lewis Carroll Easter Egg that's the
closest this movie gets to the source by
the way so she made it back to London
the same year you can learn more about
this journey home and Alice through the
Suez Canal a female captain in 1875
really
I like Alice as much as the next board
movie goer but this movie stretches the
bounds of reality a bit too much as the
movie will go on to take great advantage
of for lazy humor sake you and the
Wonder been expected for over a year
I'm afraid to ask Oh possibly lost yours
see not sure how they knew to meet Alice
at the docks a year behind schedule but
couldn't pass along news that her main
financier is dead in case you weren't
aware this impossible butterfly is
magical as there's a handy sound effect
to let you know no other company is in
the business of hiring female clocks let
alone ships captains and did you hear
the one about the wife being in the
kitchen sign over the vessel and you
will redeem the house honestly all this
is rushed and up but not as rushed and
up is that dress sea captain is no job
for a lady this feels like an argument
mother and daughter should have had
before she served a year or more as an
actual sea captain last thing I want is
to end up like you widowed with a bratty
kid can't blame her then she storms off
and this is the first movie all over
again
this might as well be a roll credits
here I think also why this house this
room in this mirror even if the movie
ends up offering a lame reason for it
it's random as stupid as hell next movie
a magic oven will be Alice's portal in
Wonderland curious you spent the last
movie in an alternate reality why would
you find anything weird to be curious Oh
No
maybe don't sit so close to the edges of
things something and he will be gone
before oh who will be gone the goddamn
pronoun game invades Wonderland to
infuriating results and do mind your
step he said that instead of just
outside that door as a free fall in the
sky because he didn't really want her to
mind her step he just wanted to give the
audience a lap because he knew full well
what was outside that door Point Break
Alice edition Alice survives this
presumably because she's the size of an
ant but actually I don't think she's
tiny anymore here in this place given
the size of this garden pool but wait
was I say Oh getting sent it twice let's
move on thankfully half the character
she met last movie are currently having
art class around the very flower bed she
just fell into and I'm more certain than
ever Alice is just taking drugs and are
being forced to watch her hallucinations
thank God your clothes rank with your
body am i right almost to see Alice
naked except for calculating calculating
forty percent of this movies audience
claim what a new scheme of odds can
raise any sort of smile we'd rather
hoped you might help us save him so you
assholes brought Alice back here because
the Mad Hatter stopped smiling
do I have that right the blue paper hat
that just happened to be right where
they were for some reason that triggered
had her to remember everything that ever
happened to him in his life Hatters
house is a hat because subtlety see this
his head survived my family must have
too terrible logic that will prove true
we had a terrible fight I never said I
was sorry when I have to child hmm okay
Hatter has some daddy issues fine not
only were they not addressed last movie
they feel super tacked on to this movie
just to justify an ALICE return plot
myath could bring my family back to me
all at once I want to say of course you
can and no she can't she said to make
him better I must bring his family back
that's it
cannot be unless it could these movies
in a nutshell go back in time how the
Kronos fear I mean the time Turner none
of us can use it because we've already
been in the past
so was Alice she's been to Wonderland at
least twice before it's not impossible
merely I'm possible this lion made it
into the movie in the hands of time it
is I'm sorry
time is a he she says this instead of
saying I'm sorry time is a person the
director and set designer had an obvious
disagreement about the definition of
enough cobwebs fine times Castle
borrowed a chronosphere
travel back in time to Horan vendor's
days save that his family from being
killed and thereby saved the Hatter
when you put it like that yes it does
sound cool I see your see no evil speak
no evil hear no evil reenactment movie I
don't understand its importance or
relevance but I do see it good job on
the three wise monkeys reference at an
odd time
really stupid decisions okay here are 45
cents for this Sacha Baron Cohen time
master bull scene which is just a huge
time when sting MacGuffin of tree I
started writing since normally but got
really annoyed and decided to go with
this massive sin bath and lest you don't
believe me here's a sped-up version of
all the sins I root for this scene
before deciding to go wholesale oh man
that's bad Oh member that glad we're
fast-forwarding this it's like a shit
how convenient that Alice knows how to
navigate a ship thankfully this time
machine bubbles she conveniently figured
out how to work after 30 seconds has a
Mad Hatter setting which ties nicely
with her personal goals for using this
time machine also Alice is going back in
time and Wonderland sequel wants to have
its cake and eat its prequel to I don't
know what that means that it's vaguely
dirty sounding but I still think it's an
accurate statement what is that even
possible now that she's in the past does
time do you have multiple Curless fears
are you screaming for no reason take
care dear Alice all I hopes fly with you
Anne Hathaway is the real villain of
this movie I don't mean Marana the White
Queen
I specifically mean Anne Hathaway roland
emmerich did the production a favor and
stepped in to direct this sequence so as
to help make it less believable looking
the chronosphere randomly adjusts to a
very important day that alice didn't
know about and wasn't looking for also
it just so happens that almost
everything she needs to know to finish
her adventure takes place there however
would you stop people from laughing put
a bag on her head yep movie is seriously
attempting to make you feel sorry for
the Queen of Hearts that's actually
happening people of wits and wits and
wit's end really are you trying to piss
me off by describing me when watching
this movie the ceremony was attended by
75% humanoids 4% frog fish things a
rabbit a cat a dog - monkey things and
to Harry Potter Griffiths if you to be a
hat wealthy of the high top name Johnny
Depp is four years older than Rhys Ifans
the actor playing his father the
princess a crown do you know what this
means to us he's telling you right now
if my father sent you to change my mind
you will alice doesn't immediately say
no you sent me to change your mind you
idiot and so the scene continues for
some time
it never happened that'd be no horn
fiendish day now get back to 1875 and
kill Hitler's 15 year old mother Alice
realizes that to save the day with time
travel she'll actually need to use time
travel to go even further back than she
thought and I want to die also oh sure
was nice of the princess to tell his
whole story about her sister's accident
right at the moment so Alice could hear
it and realize what to do and we're back
in a pirate's movie again smoothie is
like Jack Sparrow went on a date with
Tim Burton and ended the evening king
Salvador Dali in a cheap motel owned by
the Bates family do what why are you
even still characters in this movie what
the fuck going on three tinks untie
links mm-hmm I am time why is Sasha
Baron Cohen doing a Christoph Waltz
impression for this character she took
something from me I would not say what
it was but it was the chronosphere which
lets her travel through time but I'm
still able to do the same thing even
without the chronosphere which is rather
convenient if you ask me but whatever no
room plenty of Lube ladies and gentlemen
this movie's definition of comedy it's
great that the chronosphere has pictures
that are significant to the movies
characters to indicate which time she is
traveling to imagine if it had other
characters from another story that we
aren't familiar with that would be very
confusing
maybe stakes yeah you cut that kind of
close although that ink drawing on the
paper time choosing apparatus and your
time machine doesn't seem to offer much
control on when you arrive he makes the
best at wit's end who's looking to make
you one instead of saying no I have to
go save you by stopping a horrible
accident Alice goes with him Alice is
really stupid I think you'll each go two
tops you can have the cross I don't want
the cross already I think the Queen of
Hearts deserves to have an accident that
makes her head huge she's jerk
now out of my kitchen I can't believe
the Queen has to cook this is by far the
most unrealistic part of the film the
truth at usual Hey is on may say why is
that you wait for no man
puns here get your ice-cold buns here
stop you'll ruin it god damn it I'm
getting upset this movie is making me
angry and you know what happens when I
get angry I cuss even more than normal
times too hard on him Zenit you weren't
even here lady you saw a kid crying and
guess the dad was a dick to it which
yeah it's true and stuff but my point is
you didn't see she maybe that kid just
got spanked for lying or stealing Turks
or some eatle room and she doesn't even
take the Hat so she wasted almost all
her time to stop the accident by
coming here with taran and then not
buying a hat seems worth it but I'll
tell you this if she's too late to stop
the accident and some more hijinks
happen I'm gonna be pissed
another chick is the worst chrome hider
ever it didn't eat any tots why these
crusts under your bed okay first of all
if those crusts were actually under the
bed you wouldn't be able to see them
this easily second of all yeah the
Wendy's mascot sister didn't do anything
wrong here the other chick ate the tart
and you know what that seems like
standard simply curry to me not an
excuse to run away like this chick does
and of course she's gonna hurt herself
Alice learns the lessons of 12 monkeys
the hard way you can't change the past
when you around wasting time at the
Hatter shop you mean this movie is
pointless be2 that conclusion by about
an hour movie happens if time dies I'm
only asking because well he's time and
he's also one of this movie's
antagonists if not the main one which
means he either has to die or get
banished or in prison or something none
of which would seem to leave him free to
be you know time Hardesty wait
you know the Hatters family didn't die
on that day do you seriously need to go
back to that day as a witness to figure
out where they are in present day can't
you just go back to present day and tell
hatter his family's alive and then start
a search for them I'm looking big as
this Wonderland world anyway it's like
England sighs right thankfully and
apparently all mirrors or portals for
Alice I'm all for it as long as it
brings us closer to the end but it's
still bullshit
now she's not even in Wonderland anymore
oh great now she needs to find another
mirror to go back and then figure out
what time period in wonderlands history
she's even fucking in and it's gonna
give this movie an excuse to keep going
another 30 minutes or more in goody
three I'm gonna break the physical
blu-ray disc of this movie once I'm done
sitting it I mean it takes bookcase of
female hysteria dude you should have
beers with the guys from the beginning
of the movie that barely think a woman
can even keep the books you get along
great in Hollywood doctors do not squirt
out part of the medicine ducking test if
a syringe is working how you ever got
started on this troupe I will never know
but knock at the off Alice needs to
escape this facility yet upon seeing
stairs she goes up that is a terrible
strategy for escape because helicopters
haven't been invented yet and she's not
Jason Bourne but she is Jason Bourne
what the fuck this is now the second
item vital to someone's livelihood that
Alice has stolen for her own selfish
ends also let's hope the cabbie and his
family don't starve to death
I really don't know if that horse is
insured the time machine destination
parchment shows a monster and Alice
doesn't even try to change it to
something else before proceeding
cheating lightning dragon attacks Alice
while she's still time-traveling and
also my life right now part of all this
movies bull
spotting the Hatters family from this
distance and a goddamn forest fire is
among the bulkiest
the astonishing thing isn't that the
Hatters family survived a monster attack
it's that a paper hat survived a fire
he's badly ticking what's he dying from
missing his family and suddenly since
the last movie time wasted time at T
with the goofballs instead of just
coming here first to the lair of the
person he's an evil League with is away
boy time is for some reason intimidated
by this regular Wonderland person sure
she yells a lot but time clearly has
more power than any character in this
movie and strangely chooses to be a
brash dick to everyone except the Red
Queen the only reason these guards are
made from vegetables is so she can do
this otherwise vegetable guards make no
sense whatsoever
she's the Queen of Hearts about the
queen of veggies this movie is a
dickhead Alice had time for a costume
change before saving Hatter's family
this pan upshot is some weird omage to
scooby-doo Oh they've been turned into
aunts eyes people and put in an ant farm
of course also thank God he noticed this
right and another thank God for the fact
that the real ants didn't somehow kill
and eat the shrunken human family once
they were imprisoned in the ant farm and
for the fact she managed to keep this
family and take it with her after being
banished in the last movie oh no now the
evil person has the chromosphere and
she's gonna go back in time and learn
the same you can't change the past
lesson Alice learn but it'll take 20
more minutes and basically consume the
finale which is awesome
how does she know how to drive this
thing even Alice fumbled around a bit
before figuring it out heck smoke it up
she ate my snow so having the evil
chicks employees help the heroine
because they've been mistreated by the
evil chick is so Wizard of Oz I think
it's considered passe but if it'll get
me closer to the end credits I'll
overlook it just kidding I won't
I've got to go now because seeing her
former self not only killed both hers
but also apparently kills the castle
both hers were in I think I'm supposed
to feel bad about Anne Hathaway's
character turning to red and being
frozen in place but honestly that she
did with the tart crumbs that's bad
enough I'm fine seeing her get
ironically punished
[Music]
the end I hope oh so our world is fine
come that Alice shouldn't stolen that
time snitch oh give a hunka movie you're
a boner biting bastard uncle movie
reverse of everything we just spent the
last 10 minutes on fun I love how time
turns out to be a good guy
only after literally being forced to see
the truth about the Red Queen and Alice
he's time he couldn't have seen this
moment happened ahead of time and just
be a reasonable dude the whole movie in
the end it all boils down to sister
issues in that pink tart which still
makes this the Red Queen's fault since
she was bogarting all the non crust
parts of the tarts and she probably will
because movie but she probably shouldn't
because tart so all the evil stuff was
what a cruel portrayal of a woman
suffering from mental illness caused by
a severe brain injury also Anne Hathaway
is getting off way too easy
his family generally ignored or hated it
before but now they will love him solely
because he made them big again and not
because they actually love him whatever
I'll take what I can get at this point
but it's anyone I'm afraid he most
certainly is not Alice got done with her
Wonderland adventure literally just in
time to save her family's future
come into the fire this is a lovely room
of death have you ever had a dream neo
that you were so sure was real see I
used to think time was a thief snobby
sorry Thomas big cam came on let that
micro bonding no dark organ and seize
the moment to sit that time is a friend
to no man I am nomad cool pan up over a
giant clock shot but I'll remind you
this is a level within a level of what
was already probably a drug overdose
induced dream state let's not make like
physics is all that important okay it's
the time guys Castle so of course it has
to literally be a giant clock yep she's
still wearing that terrible dress why
did the gate open for is it automated is
there no security here does it open for
everyone yeah you don't care you just
want to get to the scene where she talks
to the time God and I can't blame you
even when I myself get stuck on the
mundane questions of the event
dialogue like this I'm going to guess
this giant frog washing dishes back here
signifies that this is Wonderland
because human sized frogs don't exist in
regular human land which makes me wonder
how much power this bore at Time Lord
has if he only has power over the
wonderland realm and also holy Sh is
that a portrait of a Gungan nearly
two-hour movie has time for the magical
dressing of the time character who
definitely hasn't already been self
indulgent whatsoever Selene I must give
some of myself for you to have me movie
basically admits to the stupidity of
personifying time while time maintains
the same properties that it does in the
real world couldn't he just be the
keeper of time or something do disturb
it concise well I can make because if
there's one thing I do not like it is
people who are unable and willing or
under man compelled to form short
sentences irony friend is in mortal
danger yeah but like why nothing
actually happened to make a meal there
was no curse or spell no physical
ailment he basically threw a temper
tantrum and changed his physical
appearance
that's not mortal danger that's going
golf discount Wonderland Big Ben
magnificent grand
somehow this is the mother clock despite
the entire castle being a giant clock
that kills most folks that approach this
castle so the clock and the clock dude
with a clock in his chest or one got it
weird an arbitrary but got it
no no Sofia how is the grant clock and
yet mere seconds ago you were
manipulating time with your chest clock
to speed up her speech the Evil Queen of
Hearts is such a frequent guest here at
the time castle that she has her own
heart-shaped entrance and wasn't she
banished in the last movie my dad of
course the time guy Alice needs help
from is in love with the main antagonist
from the last movie because of course he
is of course I'm sure you're right but
that is also a huge leap in logic right
there oh look Queen of Hearts wants the
chronosphere to and right at the same
exact time alice is here for what are
the odds now wait don't calculate the
odds I'll be too depressed to hear them
out loud you ask the impossible in my
dear
I cannot give you the crumbs yeah do you
think he meant for that to rhyme or is
this just a Tim Burton production he's
somehow too good to direct Alice went
from this to this during that cut to the
time guy in Queen of Hearts she defeated
an entire Indiana Jones worthy trick
maze of many pendulums that had all
happened off screen the seconds in tick
tock land rip off the Transformers and
the minions all in one fell swoop
Alice accidentally herself into the
solution with surprising Heat